مزيد من الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا هو ما
اتفق عليه الاوروبيون في قمه غرناطه
الرئيس الاوكراني اكد ذلك
بنفسه سيكون لدينا مزيد من الدفاع الجوي
هناك اتفاقيات واضحه وهذا مهم للغايه قبل
الشتاء اسبانيا وايطاليا وفرنسا والمانيا
وبريطانيا شكرا لكم وحده اوروبيه في وجه
مخاوف من خفض الدعم الامريكي بسبب الازمه
السياسيه في
واشنطن نا كان حضوره منتظرا تحديدا بعد
مرور اسبوعين على هجوم باكو على ناغورني
كارباخ لكن الرئيس الاذربيجاني اعلن يوم
الاربعاء انه لن يحضر القمه حليفه القوي
رجب طيب اردوغان غاب هو ايضا عنها امر اسف
له الرئيس
الفرنسي اود ان اقول ان الرئيس عياف
والرئيس اردوغان هما من اتخذا قرار عدم
الانضمام الى هذه القمه وانا اشعر بالاسف
الشديد لذلك
في المقابل اكد رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شارل
ميشيل انه وجه دعوه لكل من الرئيس
الاذربيجاني ورئيس الوزراء الارميني
للحضور الى بروكسل نهايه اكتوبر في محاوله
لخفض التوتر بين
البلدين